this is weekend scramble and this week
we got nine pound outfit potato rental
and handrail arrest
I like their intro thank you for joining
in like a real news show yeah so for our
first story a passenger war ninety
pounds of clothing on the plane nine
instead of paying eighty five dollars
for carry-on for overweight like shut up
why how much more is it like fifty books
8500 I applaud the frugality and the
Brazile and yeah she's a big sweaty ass
off she's so she was super hot so she
buddy looks like one of those Kanye
clothes you know make it a fashion stay
is it worth it don't feel like sweat
through all your clothes and soil and
everyone has $85 depends on why don't
they get everyone sweats as much as you
do
okay yeah depends if you're going to
last garbage that's right that's amazing
oh no but 99 pounds worth that's a lot
I'm surprised I've closed it in snap I
choose able to wear multiple packs no
stretchy clothes it was strategic
scheana's start with the cute small
stuff underneath and then go with the
expense all of her underwear at once
she said wearing seven dresses two pairs
of shoes Why What how does she wear two
pairs of shoes on her elbows her feet
and her head oh yeah maybe around her
neck two pairs of shorts a skirt and a
cardigan where did she go so she just
said she was going on a holiday
I don't know where but it was like an
all-inclusive resort so she didn't plan
on like she didn't have a lot of money
on her so she only had about 60
something dollars or 69 euros in her
account
oh no she went on a vacation that's not
they're responsible to me
yeah oh well it's not you should stay at
home and work you bought me one she
probably won the all-inclusive because
she had like the place that she's going
to they already have all her money like
her information whatever it's
all-inclusive she didn't need to bring
money but she brought that much and it
wasn't enough because the fee was 75
euro but sometimes you got to pay for
stitches I agree with you guys that
would definitely bring more money but
for her that's her thought process or I
would have just sold those all-inclusive
[ __ ] to somebody else and pocket that
money if only got 69 bucks in my bank
account dude that's like dick sucking
money dude that's like this close to
doing 69 I hope she lives with their
parents I mean but hey we all like to
live on the edge sometimes right I
remember no that's true at 18 I would
live at that I would live on the edge on
18 hell yeah I was always playing some
gat like I would always gamble with my
debit card I'm like Oh Who am I gonna
get gas today haha and then I would
swipe it and I knew I was negative in my
account and I would swipe it and I'm
like [ __ ] yeah I get gas I was once at a
point where I could not afford a small
fries at a mcdonald's cuz you know
you're 17 years old you're working at a
coffee shop and you just like trying to
spend all the money you got when you get
like 120 bucks you're like I'm rich
[ __ ] yeah and you spend it all buy
everything that's when you gotta sell
drugs get back on your feet yeah I
wasn't hard enough I became an actor
instead arguably more disappointing to
my parents that's true so you guys what
is she like 42 like 29 30 yeah he didn't
look like she was 69 dollars in their
account and she's going on vacation I
thought she was like 18 you know I'm
like you I think a lot of people are
irresponsible though because they say
what like most of America is just a
paycheck away from being completely
bankrupt or whatever yeah I think
50-year old plus don't have much in
there like the average it's like 200
bucks in our bank account yes yeah
it's pretty crazy yeah like night no
like 70% they don't Supercenter they
don't understand basic finance yeah you
know the basic finance right now geo hot
is like inch
the crew baby is interesting what's like
what is all that like a compounded when
you combine that with the fact that so
much of the countries so much of your
country doesn't have health care all
right we get it that's cuz we don't die
we don't need health care okay yeah we
we like to party no you're absolutely
right though a really sad 200 bucks in
your bank account
yeah no health and a lot of people don't
have anything to survive the next few
months and I don't know you know it's
crazy I'm sorry to get political but
it's like such a large percentage of
those people end up voting against their
own self-interest - well a president
that like will maintain that status quo
well I mean Trump did one thing recently
where he lifted the the penalty for hell
yeah health care so we used and now we
don't have to yeah so it's like it's
like mandatory health care like
insurance they have to pay for right and
then if you can't even afford that to
pay for you get penalized no just to
force everyone to be covered because if
you're four if you're poor enough you're
supposed to go to Medicare or whatever
but then some people are just right in
the middle where you don't want to pay
for it they're young and also they can't
afford it you should be preventing it
for us then it's air force' okay so now
we don't have to pay a penalty at least
and I'm like that's the stupidest [ __ ]
ever yeah but I also think it's a
population you're hella for God because
I was I was under a Muriel's health care
when she was working at a different
company oh tightly held forgot I don't
have health care anymore stupid man what
was the crazy [ __ ] you guys ever did to
save on super demerit yeah I think you
blame her Wow beeping Marilyn her
[ __ ] job choices yeah where's your
question sorry oh I used to save a lot
so look one of the biggest things that I
when I was looking at my budget and like
what was i spending the most on it was
always food that was the most expensive
thing that then you could control cuz
you can't really control rent right like
what are you gonna do you get a roommate
you you could wrap the cheapest I mean
when I was you'd be surprised though
there's some people that books that
spend so much money on read cuz they're
so [ __ ] prideful and
I don't wanna like yeah but that's I
guess that's something that even if you
control it's still a big amount like
let's say you get a roommate and it's
like you live in a shack you're still
spending hundreds of dollars here in LA
yeah like that's still a lot right you
know what's expensive air conditioning
in the summer that shit's expensive
sweat too much Brooke just go to the
ball that's what you do to save money
you just chill at places that have AC
for free and then you you leave all the
windows you have to drive there and gas
is expensive gas is outlets bezel
dollars cuz I haven't had to pay gas in
a while I said what $60 I just saw an
article that it went up like crazy until
afford sick five I don't know cuz I know
you could save a lot of money
controlling your food and I would buy
one meal and split it into two you know
what a lot of people young dumb people
do too it's because they're so young
they want to have fun they go out party
and they spend [ __ ] Center money on
alcohol not if you're a girl what the
[ __ ] are you talking about I don't know
what a single girl that paper elbow yeah
dude I knew a girl named Hong Lee they
showed her tits for an airhead very
successful woman she was training for
for the future that girl says sup KQ
Samir has ba bum got like wow and gave
me one she gave me one yeah you became a
pimp hell yeah dude I was like [ __ ]
give me that [ __ ] cream I don't the
white one that was weird I had a friend
who's a busboy that would spend 300
bucks a weekend on alcohol yeah probably
how much he made you know it's pretty
funny a lot of people are like that like
I'll tell people about getting a
multivitamin so you can stay healthy and
up how much is it oh my god it's like 50
bucks and then oh I won 50 bucks but
they spent $300 every weekend on weed
300 bucks
I'll [ __ ] her body up or fifty bucks
that's a necessity dude yeah I'm like
that's crazy your moral vitamins make my
peeper
okay so for our next story this giant
potato is up that's what I call par oh I
know this lady where what you know yeah
she look cool I don't know her but I
follow her work she made the giant
potato I don't know lady I just know the
potato okay
this potato is on Airbnb for $200 a
night what how big is this [ __ ]
it's an Idaho it looks like this they're
known for their potatoes home so this
potato used to be toured around
oh come on potato it's a real potato all
right no no no like that they carved out
of what they they made a potato oh I
thought was a real potato dude
definitely
at some point thought it was also a real
potato I thought it was a real potato
and yeah plug [ __ ] into the wall and
power he's not a potato battery was a
giant I with you I thought it was a real
what what did it for me was they were
like it toward and I was like I don't
keep of potato alive for that wait a
minute they preserve rotting that sounds
like what does it smell this is the bath
I mean is it home it is a home shaped
like a potato it's the point a little
bit highly misleading headline this lady
though she designs a bunch of dope homes
so she was like [ __ ] I'm tired of
designing dope homes out minutina all of
her [ __ ] is unique like she's got this
hobbits house that she's building like a
hobbits community where it's like in the
hill learning Kristi wolf yeah and then
I found her because I was looking at
custom design tree homes of course it
was one of her first projects is she
built a tree house in Hawaii it's
[ __ ] sick like the showers up like on
the on the tree you could just be around
the [ __ ] leave jets you're a lucky
woman girl good for you
yeah yeah she built that if she shows
how she built it from scratch to you
thoroughly did your research that's
pretty cool she's pretty sick Wow
she does all these like unique like
projects in a hobbit house The Hobbit
house is dope she's building a community
I think I just want to be tough beats
has to be tight does she do that there's
some normal ass [ __ ] they also go on
adventures together and call themselves
the fellowship that will be pretty funny
is it is it a life-sized one like does
everyone have to like duck oh yeah yeah
or is it like scaled up so then I stand
inside you can it's like that but all
the time yeah it's so tiny I would love
that
oh I can't breathe already like I said
they would use this potato to go across
the country and like just kind of be
proud of their potato Idaho nests all
day know what Dad oh yeah and then so
they just continued that six ton potato
and so that's when they converted it
into like Kristi wolf she designed the
interior so then they converted into
like a room and then now they have this
new four ton fiberglass potato that
they're taking around what was it before
it was just a potato
until she worked her magic yeah I guess
so it was made from steel plaster and
concrete you know what's crazy like back
in the days people will be wowed by this
[ __ ] they'll be like oh there's a big
potato let's go to the [ __ ] County
Fair and look at the potato like I could
picture my grandparents doing this I
would be well right now if it was a real
potato nobody goes I agree a potato like
they'll do that for the fake potato
right Oh Oh shucks huge I would still do
it for a fake potato how come it says
it's real if it's fake it's real big
you'll know it's real no no yeah I don't
know I can't read the rest of it but
yeah I was leading on so many levels I
really just thought that you lived in it
someone grew a massive potato through
generations of Jenelle
played hard in this article have you
seen those pictures though like at the
County Fair where they have those giant
real pumpkins and squash and [ __ ]
gosh it's tight I get sad when you see a
lobster that somebody killed and it's
like their claws like this big Wow way
to kill the mood I was just thinking
about it the other day because somebody
was like look at this huge lobster claw
meeting I'm like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
lobsters like 200 years old you killed
that you [ __ ] oh really yes oh
they I guess lot they don't die lobsters
can regenerate their cells constant
forever right you're supposed to eat
what the small ones then yeah so they'll
die from like disease or some natural
cause but if nothing happens to them
though continually live and so when you
see a lot of that large they have for a
very long time and so this lady or this
dude had like this [ __ ] but it was a
closely this big and I was like dinner
you [ __ ]
gets to a point where it doesn't taste
as good like that's a good size yeah and
it's nice and juicy but then the bigger
guess and it's like you want that that's
tough me hmm all right for a last story
I like crab better anyway oh so for the
last story how dare you disobey
validated am i cool factor Isaac - hey
mommy got this cool [ __ ] out here dude
she's army I'm trying to move on okay
he's drama came lobster firmly oh this
woman is Canadian woman I like crab
better - that's been fighting a 10-year
long court battle for [ __ ] battle
course I'm sorry court battle was a
Canadian court battle yes for 10 years
because his woman was fined for not
holding the escalator handrail this
Canadian courts death there where the
white wigs - I don't think so hope
you're not something like European dia
and some Asian courts like the Hong Kong
British
right yeah those British one but it
looks ridiculous I don't think we have
to fast really it does
I don't know they where the Koala hats
I'm sorry Jamie so where was this where
was she from this was in the city of
love all in Quebec Quebec okay yeah oh
no no so they're French so they wouldn't
wear the Captain Crunch outfit oh yes
yes
so she said that back in 2009 she was
riding the escalator at a subway station
when a police officer told her to
respect the pictogram on the escalator
that some respect on the pictogram yes a
caution hold it then rail in French and
so she refused to obey the officer
officer
yeah so then she ended up getting into
an argument with him oh no no she was
detained and she got a $100 ticket she
didn't use the handrail for refusing to
hold the rail and another $320 ticket
for failing to identify herself she was
handcuffed and detained for 30 minutes
that was just a power trip though it
sounds like a pride issue that is a
power trips like you do this they don't
want to do it oh you don't want to know
I agree I think on both ends she must
have been pretty damn disruptive for him
to like it was it was just gonna be a
warning it was like hey maybe you should
hold the handrail on the penny scale
this is a ten if I was what was the
security guard or something no it's a
cop right I was a police officer at some
last thing I would give a [ __ ] about put
your head on the run I don't want it I
give a [ __ ] it's like yeah I guess I
don't care who cares dude I know you
could get in trouble for not putting
your head on a handrail I thought it was
suggestion you can because this police
officer had like misconception that it
was the law to hold on to the handrail
that's gonna Oh ask for some reason I
was thinking stairs that's even funnier
let me this cop is yeah I like to lick
the climbing a rope yes sideways why
can't it still be the stairs like this
though yeah it's just funnier when
someone holds the [ __ ] stair rail
if you want to be extra [ __ ]
law-abiding one hand at a time yeah
let's touch it got it
and I'm not trying to get arrested yeah
I know she was acquitted of her crime in
2012 what if you don't want dirty as
germs on your hands
yeah wet around the world on every
single escalator going like these
[ __ ] lawbreakers so then she was
acquitted in 2012 but then she followed
her own lawsuit against the city arguing
that she was not obligated to hold the
escalator handrail or identify herself
in front of the police she's lost twice
already
and courts she will not give up she's
stubborn who the fool on yep so now her
cases it was heard by a Supreme Court of
Canada oh look you went to support what
a valid use of taxpayer money they must
be so mad remember when you said the
penny was that a ten yeah I think it's
now at what is it at now like a twelve
it's just two of the most petty human
beings on earth met each other [ __ ]
petty [ __ ] and so is she
it's like you're acquitted no no no I'm
not no no no no better lawyer up [ __ ]
Supreme Court here we come it's like for
what a cheetah like it's some civil
rights nobody gives a [ __ ] man might I
ask is this woman white yeah I'm just
wondering
she's clearly Mexican we're known for
doing that oh yeah we'll go to court for
years I'm assuming that she's had to pay
for some legal fees oh for sure what if
she had a lawyer that was in the family
or something so yeah I don't know see
how this case turns out that is the
queen of petty both of them I bet the
cop to the cop is out there like Oh
sacre bleu no [ __ ] way man so much
money I just would never spend money
like that on my time ten years she
probably thinks it's for justice you
know nobody was a [ __ ] lady dude that
means there's nothing going on
she thinks it's she's today's Rosa Parks
it's a weird crusade to beef that's a
weird Hill to die on hey do you guys
learn about American civil rights in in
Canada
oh we do a little bit that's great
man we don't learn a [ __ ] about Canada
but now I know you guys don't know
anything I know we don't even know [ __ ]
about other states weird that way yeah
we got a lot of state pride I did notice
that like the discrepancy between the
law like so many things are handled to
the state level and they're so different
yeah yeah things like marriage [ __ ]
about [ __ ] are [ __ ] than anything
else dude yo Canada got Meese which is
PO for moose Oh for real that is not
true it's one of the suggested plural
okay what is what is it will moose moose
I see now what is it just a moose moose
gang yeah you see those moose over there
yeah that one that's not like you Tom
that's fine that sentence would not
change even if it was me so you see
those nice over there Joe was trying to
make it sound like it was so
uncomfortable for him to say it's cuz
you know it's normal I want to be
grammatically correct you know also know
for poutine yeah
[Music]